you ready to go we are going on a
mission
Oh from you just from the counter no I
picked up in my bookbag Jen we're never
gonna get there
gee I wonder why gee my fault as always
we're on a secret mission a secret road
trip if you will
- Beverly house Beverly we're going to
Beverly Hills on a free well I'm not
actually Beverly Hills yes Beverly it's
Beverly place I'm not sure that makes a
difference I'm not really sure either
way there's like one
GameStop in the entire Los Angeles area
it has the galaxy Nintendo 3ds and I was
like yeah okay cool we'll cruise up on a
Friday
cheers to the freakin begin let's get
this deal yeah I also say that we have
to be back here in an hour and a half we
do because the dog has to go to the vet
why don't you just order online yeah but
then I wouldn't get it until next week
you might have to actually put some
silly traffic's it was so silly okay
let's cruise we gotta go toss cruise I
don't know
Superman dad you got me - I'm gonna have
to play something what should I play did
you hear the news that adrenaline each
left and the buckles and Terry I so
loves that Oh shake it up I'm turning up
years old what did you say this song is
21 years old I did let's discuss it no
no no no how many of you guys heard this
song before so are we going into
Gamestop
yeah well I gotta get my thing we're
here now cuz we're doing Maddie well not
even cooking stuff then you want to go
to gamestop I get a kiss give mommy kiss
good let me doesn't wanna get his lemon
can't isn't what I guess we are here
gonna get the good I even wore my galaxy
leggings for this wonderful affair look
at these great leggings
Oh support new boy thank you
I call about getting a yes okay the
funny thing is I was like ear pencils
like so match he was so excited the
journey has the charger I do yes but I
actually might want to get Jason to USB
yeah the two pieces per curiam alright
cool very good boy we got it
I'm so excited I cannot wait cannot
weekend away
the most beautiful antenna 3d s ever
like it's so freakin beautiful we had an
emergency for the baby boy look at him
[Music]
so core nati has an anal gland infection
on his left gland the poor sweet little
baby all my goodness it breaks my heart
now I gotta wear clone and he's got to
come back for a check-up in a week any a
thing in the biotics my baby I'm so
sorry I know it's not good the saddest
of days we successfully were able to get
our D s and this poor dog he just kept
licking his little but I was like we
have to take him I take him to the vet
so often because anytime anything is
just sort of out of the ordinary I take
him because I want to make sure he's
okay and this time he has a little bum
infection right he's not robot oh here's
his baby drugs quantity fun my gosh
helmet oh boy someone's hi baby
I know I'm sorry take it easy on
Maddie's heart there you go there you go
now you match mommy now you match me
what do you make it I'm sauteing the
rice I'm going to be making a creamy
Parmesan risotto for dinner
Betty you hungry honey you look hungry
Wow it looks amazing all right let's try
it what they're not too hot
oh wow rawr good show hot like you got a
time okay that's bad idea I can't wait
I'm so hungry 9 he's been obsessed with
his little blob boy he like destroyed
her little whiskers as you can see it's
not open yet I will do an official
unboxing tomorrow I want to have it set
up very very nice in my nice little
white unboxing setup so look at I
tomorrow and I
see you guys then I'm so excited it
looks so freakin pretty mm-hmm
see you later bye oh we're going to
different challenge videos so one for
her Channel another one for mine and
that's gonna be really fun
we haven't figured out when we're gonna
release it yet so it might already be
out or it might not be out who knows